what's next for you Lamarr are you gonna  try and play again yeah I still got it  you look like you could still play yeah  okay okay let me ask you this there are  certain websites that will follow you  around and put up pictures and post up  which we understand is not always true  how do you deal with that and handle  that Petey got the first interview with  Lamar Odom after his near-death  experience at that Nevada brothel last  year and now he's opening up in detail  with the doctors I didn't know until so  Chloe had told me I couldn't I couldn't  even speak at the top okay I was scared  the interview was taped before Odom  entered a rehab facility earlier this  month a source tells ET the former NBA  player is seeking help to get better for  his kids  [Music]